willkommen zur jubiläumssendung mallorca
das freut mich sehr dass wir jetzt hier
stehen mit ganzen über tausend
abonnenten
es ist ja schon fast fast mehrere al
fast zwei jahre einen halb ich weiß
nicht wie lange wir es schon auf youtube
sind wie lange flug us machen
wir haben ja sofort mit der app
gestartet und in dem video würde ich
gerne über das reden was wir alles
geschafft haben was für komische sachen
wie auch gemacht haben den videos und
was für tolle sache wir gemacht haben
und was er in zukunft auf uns zukommen
wird
naja also rückblickend sieht man auch an
diesem posten haben dass eine kleine
geschichte
unsere bisherigen aktivitäten
präsentiert weiß noch wir haben
angefangen mit seinem video auch über
luther und luther roll sagte dass noch
was stichwort lothar ohl ja in der tat
das interessante ist dass dir das
überhaupt nicht aufgefallen ist über
über bis zur veröffentlichung eigentlich
da habe ich ja ein stück papier in den
mund genommen und gegessen
wir machen oben rechts und links
einsatzstelle also für mich war
eigentlich sehr interessant dass wir
angefangen haben mit einer ganz weißen
wand dahin einfach sehr lieblos also
zwar mit liebe aber es sei lieblos aus
ein lokales poster und total schlechte
kamera qualität soundqualität immens
schlecht ich war aufgeregt wie sag ich
ja ich hatte blackouts darüber was sie
ich habe gar nicht mehr merken können
was du sagst ich habe die frage nicht
verstanden
ich habe mich gefühlt wie hat das ist
völlig normal also das ist nichts
ungewöhnliches aber du hast dich sehr
gut entwickelt ja danke schön
ich finde es auf jeden fall toll dass
auch das interesse bei den zuschauern
steigt also wir arbeiten noch daran dass
es sozusagen immer besser wird für euch
dass die inhalte annehmbarer mehr auf
den punkt gebracht sind dass man mehr
mehr auch als außenstehender versteht
was für sie eigentlich macht ohne
reduktionistischen zu sein und
dementsprechend haben wir jetzt eine
ziemlich große vielfalt auf zwei sein
video ist kannst du darüber ein bisschen
was sagen sie haben ganze bandbreite an
formaten wir haben die auch dank der
realisiert werden konnten wir haben zum
beispiel dieses format viele view damals
zwischen fünf sendungen ich mache einen
link oben rechts zur playlist wo
wirklich studentische stimmen mal
geltung bekommen und verschiedene fragen
an sie gerichtet werden und mit schöner
musik untermalt werden und schöne
stimmungsbilder generiert werden auch
aus englischen garten glaube ich eine
schöne locations die du da abgefilmt
hast dann haben wir natürlich jetzt das
format des livestreams das ist ganz
neues gibt seit diesem sommer dass wir
eben seminar aufzeichnungen gleich
direkt übertragen und eben auch öffnen
für den live kommentar das ist eine neue
sache den hammer experteninterviews nach
wie vor wir haben jetzt allerdings zeigt
die ja auch so videos interviews von
tagungen workshops dann mache ich auch
oben rechts ein reines moral psychology
workshop also und sind praktisch keine
grenzen gesetzt weil wir uns als eine
plattform verstehen für verschiedene
philosophische inhalte
unterschiedlichste art und wir möchten
auch die zuschauer anregen im
kommentarbereich wünsche zu äußern was
für weitere formate ihr wollt wo wir uns
noch verbessern können was wir
intensivieren wollen sollen das bitte in
die kommentare schreiben
ja wir sind ja auch ziemlich flexibel
also unser team hier kameramann denn ist
unsere der philipp wir machen das ja
sehr flexibel alles deswegen sind wir
offen für neues und
lediglich vorschläge auch anzunehmen
die der zukunft wollen wir das noch ein
bisschen intensivieren wir haben ein
forschungsprojekt beantragt mit
rechtsmitteln das wird wahrscheinlich
bewilligt werden das heißt wir werden
uns weitere kamera ausstattung zu legen
wir werden vielleicht auch mal ein green
screen hinten installieren also mit
besseren noch grafischen effekten wir
werden weitere themen sendungen
begründen weitere formate wir werden den
livestream weiter experimentell
austesten wir werden auch jetzt neues
format einführen wo professorinnen und
professoren der fakultät miteinander
diskutieren über ein bestimmtes thema
zum beispiel soll jetzt mal 1
stattfinden über aristoteles und platon
und streiten sich ein streitgespräch die
professoren kann man sich schon
überlegen wer das sein wird wir verraten
es noch nicht aber das ist uns
jedenfalls zugesagt worden
also hier auch an die dozentinnen und
dozenten der lmu wir sind sehr
interessiert daran dass sie sich auch
hier engagieren und mit uns mitmachen
also wenn jetzt jemand interesse hätte
sogar rein zufällig bei philo carsten
video darüber über über seine inhalte zu
machen als als jetzt einen dozenten
dozenten und studenten im master
studierenden doktoranden doktoranden
alles okay also die könnten jetzt
einfach sagen hey hallo york sowie in
den videos sogar sage und dann wärst du
werden die breite also oder hallo marcel
oder hallo dennis wir haben die
infrastruktur wir sind die plattform wir
machen sonst nichts wenn wir uns das
thema interessant erscheint bieten wir
euch ihnen hier die rahmenbedingungen
die ausstattung die technische
ausstattung wir schneiden die videos wie
bearbeiten sie nach dank euch und wir
publizieren sie und wir sorgen dafür
dass die kommentare ordentlich sind wir
achten darauf das ist eine
win-win-situation und dazu möchten wir
wirklich hier ja das angebot
unterbreiten und auf den auf rückmeldung
geil sehr gut ja also es freut mich dass
wir auch jetzt so eine art meta sendung
machen über fluggast das hat gefehlt und
ich hoffe auch dass die zuschauer jetzt
ein besseres bild davon haben wie das
hier alles abläuft genau und die nächste
meter sendung machen wir dann zu den
nächsten zu den 10.000 übrigens sagen
wir haben schon gewisse prognosen das
wird jetzt nicht mehr allzu lange dauern
die steigerung des quote ist vielleicht
exponentiell ein bisschen also geht
steil nach oben es gibt natürlich immer
noch verbesserungsbedarf ganz klar da
bitte auch wieder in die kommentare ein
schreiben aber wir haben bald mehr was
sie als zuschauer machen können das ist
auch sehr hilfreich da der youtube
algorithmus so ein bisschen tricky ist
wäre es klasse wenn ihr das dieser
glocke im offenen kanal einfach
anschaltet da gibt es eine glocke dann
bekommt ihr auch als interesse habt
immer benachrichtigung wenn wir neue
videos posten dass es nicht für alle der
fall also wenn ihr da bock habt gerne an
schalten dann unterstützen wir uns auch
und gerne teilen nicht glaubt josef
wichtiges grundthema was auch viel mehr
platz einnehmen kann bei leuten die ja
auch nicht im thema drin sind und das
ist ja auch unser ziel eine möglichst
breite masse sehr guten qualität
irgendwie flüsse viel zu vermitteln
ja genau wir wollen aktuell sein wir
sind der auffassung dass philosophie und
internet sich nicht widersprechen
sondern dass philosophie im internet
eine struktur analogie besitzen also
dass das die diskursiven charakter der
philosophie gut abbildet ist internet
und wir wollen dazu anregen dass
philosophie breiter diskutiert wird
aktueller wird live wird und dass wir
immer neue impulse bekommen
vielen dank ich denke wir haben jetzt
ganz gut beschrieben beschreiben können
was wir hier machen
dank ihr denn es an filmen guter
kameramann und philipp für all die
andere arbeit die hier im backround
stattfindet
ich freue mich auf alles kommende
wirklich und bedanke mich eigentlich von
herzen für jeden der hier zuschaut und
interesse sein interesse durch alles
durch seinen zuschauern durch sein
abonnieren durch nette nachrichten die
wir bekommen begründet bin ich sehr
dankbar für und auch an dich jörg vielen
dank dass du uns allen hier so viel
ermöglicht hast und ja einen youtube
channel aufgebaut hast mit uns der über
tausend abonnenten hat der danke klar
zurück an euch um euch wenn es auch
nicht möglich gewesen dank auch an die
zuschauer und ich würde sagen bis zu
einer nächsten folge bei philo kaarst